look at these two paper bags
they don't appear very different but
they sound different
one of these is a real everyday paper
bag
and the other one is a silent prop
this fake paper bag was an innovation
thought up by prop maker
tim schultz props is always about
solving a problem
and one of those problems is everyday
objects that don't look distracting
but sound distracting i often say that a
sound guy can hear
grass growing when you're on location
silencing some props like drums can be
fairly simple
like adding a drum mute
[Music]
but others require getting a bit more
creative
like with pool balls which were too loud
for these two bar scenes in season one
of friday night lights
nice shot property master scott reeder
needed to find a ball that would create
a softer sound on
impact first he experimented with
plastic balls from a ball pit
they were much quieter but he couldn't
get paint to stick to the surface
then he remembered a trick he used on
1991's
necessary roughness during a shot where
a character is thrown onto a pool table
in a bar fight
reader swapped real pool balls with
racquetballs so the actor would land on
something softer
we didn't really clue in at the time
that oh you know these would be good for
sound listen to how real pool balls
sound
it's too noisy compared to the
racquetballs
much better
to get it to look like the real thing
reader added a layer of primer to make
sure the paint stuck
followed with a glossy spray to give off
the signature shine of a real pool ball
you gotta pick them up to tell that
they're not real
and reader also had to know when to swap
the props in
if actors are playing in a scene we'll
typically do
real if the camera is going to see them
hit the ball
and then when the camera goes to where
it's just on their face
we'll throw the fake ones on the table
so they can actually play
pool that way the sound man can catch
the dialogue
prop masters don't always need to find a
replacement
some silent props are made by just
modifying the real thing
for example in this scene in tammy
actress melissa mccarthy needed to wear
a paper bag on her head to hide her
identity and another one on her hand to
hide a gun schultz said it was important
for her to use the real thing
but a real paper bag would sound
something like this just get caught you
want some pies
get a pile for you get a pile for
quieting these real bags down
meant adding more weight to them so
schultz sprayed the bags with a mix of
water and glycerin which is typically
used to add the appearance of sweat or
water droplets on anything from human
skin to beer bottles
it takes quite a bit of well it takes
time and finesse because you don't want
to overdo it
he also taped the bags inside to hold
them together and prevent them from
crumbling
but this fix was only temporary since
the bags would eventually lose their
color and fall apart over time
and this wouldn't work for when actors
have to handle bags consistently
so for other projects schultz developed
a quiet durable
alternative using fibrous non-woven
fabric
this is actually the same material as
coffee filters
to make it look like the real thing
schultz wraps the fabric around a mold
then he glues and folds the sides by
hand we're trying to copy the bottom of
the
of a standard bag that is really made by
a machine
it's important to get the corners so
that they're square
a lot of times we'll when we're using
them we'll
crinkle them and make them look more
used so they
have a more realistic look instead of
cutting it smooth
it's going to cut it with a little
jagged edge to it this fabric can be
used on other paper products as well
like when this butcher in the kaminsky
method talks to alan arkin while
grabbing a handful of cold cuts
that butcher paper fake
it's these small handheld props that
give prop masters the most trouble
especially in scenes with dialogue for
example an actor with a drink will
likely hold it near their midsection
where microphones are often attached
it's especially important to make sure
whatever is in that drink doesn't
produce
any unwanted sounds so if you're
watching a show like entourage with lots
of scenes at parties and bars
it's safe to assume that these ice cubes
are all fake
but not all fake ice is the same plastic
cubes don't melt
which is great for continuity but
they're still really loud
so when sound is crucial schultz often
opts for another type of fake cubes
these ones made out of silicone
these rubber cubes can either be molded
in trays or ripped apart
since the final product floats in a
glass they look more convincing
and best of all they're completely
silent
background actors can move this stuff
around without having to
worry about the sound so when this
waitress walks by with a tray full of
cups with ice
you can hear what times dinner was
starving and
not what time is dinner while ice cubes
only pop up in certain moments
other loud materials are everywhere like
plastic
everything from sandwich bags to potato
chip bags make
loud crackles so schultz will create
fake ones out of vinyl
so this material this little sound
and it comes in handy for other places
you might not expect like flower
bouquets that are wrapped in cellophane
take this moment from the kaminsky
method where michael douglas's character
brings flowers to an
ailing friend if schultz had used real
cellophane for the bouquet
all the sound team would hear is what
kind of flowers over
i have no idea so he used a transparent
vinyl material to replicate the look
without all the noise
what kind of flowers are those i have no
idea
uh-huh so your daughter boy yeah
but no solution is one size fits all
noisy tissue
but a quiet bag
still doesn't solve the problem some
objects need multiple layers of silent
material to effectively kill any noise
like with these gift bags
so quiet tissue
quiet bag done
so next time you see a scene set in a
grocery store a bar
or even just around the office look
twice at the everyday objects you can
see
but can't hear
we can all thank the prop makers for
that
[Music]